S
DRILLS TIT FOR TATWING NO
ACCELERATING LD HUIN A
MATTERWIS NON  ANALYST
IDER.WHBE DO, EXPLAIN
>>IT
LET ME D.
FIRST OF A IU TOE FOR NDAREA.LEO
S SAW A MONTH E KING
ABOUT ATH.
YOU HAD RUSSIAN FORCESTHE UKD T
SYOU SEE THE PENE ERE TH WERE.
E RUSSIA ALONG HAD AE.Y HED EITI
THIS WAS THEI
C CRIMEA, THIS LAND
HERE.
IE MIE ENEMY
CO
IMPORTANT.
AT UKRAINIANS DID, THEY
D DEAND
TRVINCE,CE
THE RUSSIANS -- TO CONVINCE THE
ATTACKTHS Y WERE
BUT THEY DID I,
STUFF HERE. THEFAD EIR PRIMARY K
RUSSIANS ARE CTHE IT'S QUITETHL
CAUGHT O.
>> BUT SPIDER WAS IT A FAINT? IT
T POTENTIALLY ONE OF CPSE.
>>ERFECT QUESTION. YOU CANNO
O R EFFO
MEHEID I
PUT THPREFFORT UHETHEY'RE A PRI
EAISIA
AND THEYE DIVERTEDOS
ES DOWN REHAT YOT
THN .
IST LOOKED LIKNTH AGO.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
BECOMES A CHALLENGE FOR THE
RUSSIANS BECAUSEE FORCES ARE
Y ATED.
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
BA